The clever kid goat.
There once lived a herd of goats.
Some sheepdogs guarded them from the wolves...
...that lived in the nearby forest.
There was a tiny kid goat...
...whose mother always warned him from wandering off alone into the forest.
One day, the little goat was merely grazing...
...and wandered away into the forest.
A wicked wolf jumped out and said that he would eat him up.
The scared kid goat thought of a plan to save himself.
He requested the wolf to grant him one last wish.
The wolf agreed.
The kid goat asked the wolf to sing...
...as he had heard people say that he had a lovely voice.
The flattered wolf began to sing with great enthusiasm.
The sheepdogs heard the noise and rushed into the forest.
They nearly torn him to pieces...
...and the wolf was lucky to escape with his life.
The kid goat thanked them and apologized.
He would always listen to his elders he said.